[Evans] So if you recall the separate channels, we divided the cipher
into the message part, the key part, and the part from the S wheels,
and now we've concluded that if we can--
we're going to try 1271 possible settings.
So for 1 of those possible settings we're going to know all the key bits,
and that means if we guess the right setting the key will go to 0.
So now all that's left is the other 2 parts.
This is what we had before.
We knew that the probability of delta M being zero was greater than a half,
and it was actually about 0.61 for German
because of the likelihood of message letters being repeated.
And we knew that the probability of delta S being 0 was about 0.73,
and that's because of the structure of the machine--
that the S wheels don't advance every step.
Only when the M wheels are on a 1 do the S wheels advance.
And so now we've said if we guess right, that means the probability that the key bits are 0
goes to 1.
And it'll be 1 when we guess right.
When we don't guess right it'll be ½.
So in order to tell if we guess right,
we need to know that the probability of the cipher text bits when we guess right,
the probability of the delta Zs being 0 will be different from ½.
So the question is, what is the probability delta Z is 0 when we guess right?
And remember that what delta Z is is the XOR of delta M, delta K, and delta S.
So to solve this you need to think about all the different things
that would make delta Z equal to 0 and compute their probability.